u.s federal reserve chair jerome powell
said a fed report on central bank
digital currency cbdc would come in
early
september during a hearing on wednesday
before the u.s house committee and
financial services
most interestingly to me and a lot of
people who are in the audience here in
response to a question from republican
house member patrick mchenry powell said
the report will outline the benefits and
risks of cbdc's
as well as cryptocurrencies and stable
coins more broadly in
the hearing powell said that stable
coins need regulation
if they are going to play a major part
within u.s payment networks
listen to the 60-second clip and i'll
talk to you on the other side
and so stable coins certainly have uh
some advantages
in terms of a faster payment system and
and have some of the attributes of uh
cbdc
but there are some risks uh with uh
stable coins right now
are there not are there concerns you
have about stable coins
yeah i think the issue stable coins are
a lot like money market funds or bank
deposits or
a narrow bank depending on the terms of
them that kind of thing
but without the regulation and i think
we we have a tradition
in this country uh where you know we're
where the public's money is held in what
is supposed to be a very safe
asset we have a pretty strong regulatory
framework
around bank deposits for example or
money market funds that doesn't exist
really for stable coins and if they're
going to be
a significant part of the payments
universe which we don't think crypto
assets will be but stable coins might be
then we need an appropriate regulatory
framework which frankly we don't have
all right so there you have it folks
we've been talking about this tether
investigation uh for a month now here on
this podcast
and jim cramer's done two segments and
coffeezilla has done a segment
and the financial times has been talking
about tether
and they had their new york attorney
general
settlement and they've been banned from
working with people residing in new york
stable coins are really becoming
a risk factor here and like the u.s
federal reserve chair is saying here
people's money should be safe and stable
coins are supposed to be money
therefore it needs to be regulated it
needs to be safe and obviously it is not
and that is why people are really
concerned
about what is happening with tether also
powell made an inflammatory comment that
is making the rounds in the crypto
community right now
in which he was speaking about the
arguments in favor of
a u.s cbdc central bank digital currency
the people in crypto refer to this as
fedcoin um and here is his comment
you wouldn't need stable coins you
wouldn't need cryptocurrencies if you
had a digital us currency i think that's
one of the stronger arguments in its
favor so there you have it folks you
know people
uh in his position do not tip their
cards inadvertently
they do everything in a very predictable
well thought out manner 99.9 of the time
so there will be a central bank digital
currency and the u.s
believes that it will eliminate the need
for cryptocurrency
and for stable coins that is what
the outcome will be for cryptocurrency
and stable coins in my mind
and i've said this many times on the
program which then gets me attacked by
laser-eyed
people who've you know created burner
accounts in the last six months on
twitter
uh where they will reply have fun
staying poor
good luck with that i'm still investing
in startups i think i'll be okay
but the point here is no government is
going to give over their financial
system to a bunch of
randos globally anonymous accounts
to a currency that is not in any way
managed by a central authority so
what is the likely outcome here we saw
it in china where they banned
mining here in the united states will
they ban the mining and
of bitcoin no i don't think so but they
could put a tax on cryptocurrencies they
could make regulations that holding it
require certain conditions we already
have some of those like kyc
and anti-money laundering but the noose
is going to tighten
in the developed world and then that's
going to leave the people
participating in crypto and stable coins
to either
get legitimate and add a bunch of
expense
and to for the government to try to
maintain control of their monetary
supply
and i think this is all going to come to
a quick resolution it's been a decade of
this
it's now hit scale people are super
concerned
in our governments and governments
around the world and they're concerned
really
um for two reasons one they don't want
to see people get burned but two they
don't want to lose power so crypto
people have it right
fedcoin and governments cracking down on
crypto is because they want to maintain
control do not be naive
um these governments are not going to
give over their sovereignty
as expressed through currency to
just a random group of pirates on the
internet who believe in
uh you know a radical libertarian
approach to uh freedom of currency and
freedom from the money printing machine
at the fed
that doesn't mean they're right but that
is just uh the reality
after we invited uh bitfinex on this
week in startup episode one two four
three tether cto uh tweeted the
following
then he goes like i don't understand why
they don't speak in my clown show
i think he's referring to me so paulo if
you don't wanna come on the pod i
understand
i don't understand why you're
capitalizing
certain letters and leaving some
lowercase and
you know my twitter handle is that jason
easy to remember five characters
um you could have just mentioned me and
uh he says there are plenty of
respectable shows where we are planning
to discuss
obviously we're setting the bar a bit
higher than his show
stu and myself will happily discuss with
more serious and professional hosts
and i responded okay so you're not
coming on the show
apparently setting the bar higher means
they're going on shows that will give
easier interviews and great headlines
and here's the headline
tether's exciting future an interview
with paulo cto
bitfinex uh on the queen republic a very
popular youtube channel with
576 subscribers well done paulo i'm glad
that you set the bar so high
for somebody with 500 subscribers to
their youtube channel
no offense to the queen republic uh i'm
sure it's uh
this is a youtube channel with great
potential um but
you can tell from the title tethers
exciting future
either they it's quite possible to
either pay for this interview or in some
ways advertising on this person or they
have a financial interest
in it or it's just somebody who is
giving them a really easy time
home crowd interview if you will it
would be the equivalent of me
interviewing
the founder of one of the companies i
invested in so
we continue to uh invite tether to come
on the program
and jeremy alaire from uh their
competitor
circle which does usdc another stable
coin but that is regulated here in the
united states
um he's coming on the program and they
just announced that they will be
going public so i think we're going to
see tethers
involvement in crypto deprecate over
time and they will only be able to
operate
in unregulated markets with
uh you know people who maybe um
are of a certain profile
who need a less regulated currency in
other words
you know the people who want to be on
the up and up and who want to be
regulated will pick
to use maybe circle and i don't have any
financial interest in it or
a regulated uh coin a regulated stable
coin
and then i think what happens is over
time tether is for only people who
maybe need to be part of the underground
and who don't want people to know what's
going on with their
tokens and how they're moving money
around
twilio is the cloud communication
platform used by
uber airbnb shopify and many others not
that you need any more names i mean
think about that uber airbnb
shopify it's basically as good as it
gets you may have heard of them in the
news back in november of 2020 when they
announced their 3.2 billion
acquisition of segment one of the
world's leading customer data platforms
everybody knows segment if you're in the
industry
well twilio provides you the building
blocks to add messaging
voice and video in your web and mobile
applications they are rooted in startup
culture and they are here to help you on
that journey
twilio gives you the power to build
communication apps easily
so you can spend more time focusing on
accounts your customers
engage and delight your users while
scaling globally
all from one api powered platform from
sms
to voice to whatsapp to email thanks to
that send grid
acquisition and founder ceo jeff lawson
has been
on this program multiple times i think
the last time was episode 967 back in
2019
let's book them again and here's what
you're gonna get from twilio startup
program access to webinars made
exclusively for startups and
full support via the twilio startups
team a 500 getting started credit and
three thousand dollars in send grid
credits sign up now
twilio startups.com twist twilio twilio
startups.com twist so go get the bag
right now thirty five hundred dollars in
credits are waiting there for you to
just take them twilio startups.com
twist